I love Don Rickles you told such a great  story about Bhushan Kapoor Shammi ever  sitting eating dinner in LA yeah yeah um  Rickles comes over the table the bouche  laughs he goes Oh somebody needs braces  or something like that some nice boys  loose on that too I went to my diner  could walk up to a guy with really  [ __ ] up teeth like yeah shimmy and go  won't beauty break I mean and that way  we shan't laugh his ass I thought it was  the greatest thing ever and then I meant  fun of me he looked at me and I had my  dumb excited smile he goes is it isn't  this exciting you're meeting me isn't it  a big deal I'm right here it should be  it's a big night for you is it a thought  like that I let you out of the house  yeah yeah yeah